the impeachment inquiry against
President Trump enters a dramatic new
phase this week with the first public
hearings it's the third time in modern
history a president has faced
impeachment this morning we're looking
at what led to the resignation of
President Nixon in 1974 over the
Watergate scandal he was accused of
abusing his office just as president
Trump has been accused chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett is at the
White House major good morning so how is
this investigation different well
there's so many differences in our
country and the way institutions are
viewed the way the view media is viewed
Congress the presidency itself all those
things are different but let's go to the
investigation itself Tony the Nixon
investigation played out slowly largely
at the end in public view and the
president's attorneys were able to
amount a defense though that defense
wilted against the available evidence
president Trump's attorneys have had
very little access to the evidence or
the witnesses it's been conducted this
investigation largely in secret another
big difference is in the end because
political support collapsed President
Nixon resigned before the House passed a
single article of impeachment it's quite
clear mr. Trump will not here is Walter
Cronkite in Washington shortly before
President Nixon resigned Walter Cronkite
said all of Washington anticipated the
final act of the Watergate drama he is
quitting they hold him a victim of the
Watergate scandal that destroyed his
administration in the face of
impeachment pressure now President Trump
sounds defiant and unmovable Pietschmann
because it's the only way they're gonna
win they got nothing the Watergate
investigation began in the Senate with
Democrat Sam Ervin pleading for
Whitehouse cooperation we stand ready to
discuss the matter with you at your
convenience today's investigation has
House members passing by microphones
offering partisan play-by-play things
have just gone from very very bad to
much much worse this ridiculous charade
that the Democrats are putting him
through you can understand why the
president's frustrated when Nixon's
impeachment got to the house more than
400 lawmakers a bipartisan landslide
voted to authorize the inquiry to
investigate fully and complete
led by New Jersey's Peter Rodino this
time the impeachment inquiry vote was
plainly partisan almost all Democrats in
favor all voting Republicans opposed the
resolution is adopted
to Nixon special prosecutors Archibald
Cox and Leon Jaworski led the initial
Watergate investigations evidence was
then submitted to Congress to slow the
probe Nixon fired Cox creating a
debilitating political firestorm House
Democrat Adam Schiff is the lead
investigator now drawing mr. Trump's
outrage what broken ship is though he's
a corrupt politician Nixon's impeachment
focused on a politically motivated
burglary other political espionage and a
systemic government cover-up the story
emerged over many months
thank you very much with the current
impeachment process dealing with Ukraine
and allegations of dangling military aid
for perceived political favors has moved
much faster CBS News legal analyst
Jonathan Turley the greatest difference
is that there has been very little
evidentiary work that has been done you
know the Democrats are going from zero
to 60 in about a hundred feet charlie
also said the range of Ukraine linked
misdeeds against mr. Trump appears
smaller than the allegations that doomed
Nixon it appears they're going to go
forward largely on this phone call and
the Ukrainian controversy if they do
that it will be the narrowest
impeachment in history and they'll have
one of the most limited evidentiary
records in history the Watergate saga
unfolded slowly a CBS News special
broadcast roughly four months after the
1972 break-in tried to put the key facts
in one place we shall try tonight to
pull together the threads of this
amazing story quite unlike any in our
modern American history major there are
some intriguing similarities and
differences between these two inquiries
but if history doesn't repeat itself at
least it rhymes what are the political
implications for the Democrats as they
push along with this inquiry at this
rate and at this time speed matters and
if you move too quickly and the public
cannot catch up with the facts you're
presenting you lose or you lose you lose
in terms of public opinion being moved
by the evidence you
the public also Democrats have a high
standard to meet here impeachment is not
I dislike the president it means the
president has done something or will
continue to do something that's a threat
to the administration of the office as
we understand it that's a high bar the
evidence has to be presented the public
has to see it and evaluate it before you
can move Democrats at this pace seem to
be moving that process much more rapidly
than at least previous impeachments have
yeah well we start to see it Wednesday
major thank you very much